whenever your JavaScript doesn't work he
probably resort to scattering console
dock logs around your code and checking
the console but this can be a messy and
frustrating way to debug your JavaScript
in this video I'm going to teach you a
better way
so I have this web app here it's
actually the main project from my learn
react and redux from beginner it's a
paid professional course so it's a react
app but that's completely irrelevant
what I'm going to show you will work for
any front-end JavaScript whether you're
using a framework or not anyway this app
is broken if we do a search the
thumbnails all come back broken so what
do we do so
most people will do this they'll go to
the part of the code where we've got the
function that processes the search
results and do a consult
log on the results then go back to the
browser and reload it then you want to
bring up the console and we want to
check the results that we've outputted
and yeah and they all look fine to us so
the next step is usually to add another
console dot log somewhere else now this
way of debugging does work but it is a
bit cumbersome constantly adding and
removing console dot logs all over the
place I'm going to show you a slightly
nicer way in the code we simply remove
the console dot log and in its place we
put the word debugger now let's go back
to the browser and see what that does
so we reload in the browser and you're
going to make sure the developer tools
are open all this won't work at all we
perform our search again
now when the code hits the debugger
statement the browser stops the
JavaScript execution is paused at this
point we call this a breakpoint we can
now do some really cool things we can
inspect the current state of the code we
can see exactly where we are in the code
we can mouse over variables and it shows
their current values if you go down here
we can see a call stack showing all of
the functions that were called to get to
this point over here we can see all of
the variable scopes we've got available
at the current point and see all of the
variables in each scope and even their
current values we can even add new
breakpoints by clicking like this and a
blue arrow comes up and we press the
blue arrow down here and this moves on
to the next breakpoint or just to the
end of the code if there isn't one and
you can just remove the breakpoint by
clicking it again you can press this
down arrow here to skip into functions
or this right-facing arrow here to step
through the code one line at a time so
this goes into another function cool
somewhere down here we've got the valley
we want we thought it was a string and
this is why we've got a problem but it's
actually an object and we want the URL
property which is a string and the
debugger gives us the exact line of code
we need to go and fix it so we go back
to our code we know the exact line
number where we've got the problem
because we saw it in the debugger and
now we just fix it by adding dot URL and
of course we go down and we remove the
debugger statement so in the browser
again we reload perform another search
and now we get all our thumbnails
everything works as expected so there
you have it
breakpoints are a more professional
faster and hassle-free way to debug your
JavaScript code